i know what happens in apocalypse but
what was your initial reaction to
finding out
when you were gonna get the opportunity
to bring queenie back for hotel
that she was not gonna make it through
because i'll be honest with you uh it
upset me
i got her back and then she was gone and
i didn't know what was gonna happen down
the line so i was pissed
death doesn't really mean anything over
an american horror story i get really
really close to one of the
one of the head writers john gray and so
sometimes he oh this is yeah that's what
he did
so they were discussing bringing back a
character from kevin and john was like
can we bring back gabby because i want
to go to dinner with him
he wanted to go to dinner with me and so
because i was in chicago at the time
and so flew me back into la he's like
we'll just tell her well you know
to be a death scene and that's what we
did so that we can go to dinner and i
knew i was fine with it i knew that like
i genuinely still have socks and
underwear that's still bloody
from from that i do
i should throw them away however
death doesn't really mean anything in
the american horror story uh
universe i think i've been killed six
times
yeah does that mean anything and you
think i would have learned that lesson
after four seasons but
i was still pretty sensitive about it
that doesn't mean anything
it's really fun like death scenes are
really really really fun in american
horror story too because you
one that everyone is killed so
intricately and
beautifully sometimes poetically you
know
everyone's death is quite poetic and
usually ties into something else and you
know everything is very cyclical
in that uh universe and also you know i
get to learn how they you know
like if they have to build an extra hand
on my hand to stab
they built an extra neck and then
there's a thing on the end of a
pipe that goes down and a foot pump for
the blood and i think it's
you know it's packed being shot in the
stomach
all of the things that i do not want to
happen to me ever
but happening to me in a really safe
space
it's fun would you return to american
horror story as a performer to act in it
but also
i don't know where you're at with
directing but would you have any
interest
in directing an episode because i think
one of my favorite episodes of
apocalypse was the one that sarah
directed
it yeah sarah's episode was really
really really good really good
that was a good episode i i was shooting
with her
when she started a prepped for it yeah i
would absolutely
direct an episode of american horror
story it's
[Music]
there's so much room to play there's so
much room to learn i'm still a
you know i'm a very young director
and so i'm still learning and i think
that the lessons that i would get from
american horror story are just
so valuable yeah i would absolutely
direct it and also i would
be on the show again as a performer
[Music]
[Applause]